friends we have our french fries a
little bigger a little thicker I have
had those french fries in France and in
Luxembourg and in the UK but never in
the US McDonagh and that is the taste
for country residential culture so it
countries different days yeah
so far my favorite McDonald's food is by
far in France so we're looking forward
to see how different it is here fresh
and fatty with some skin smells of oil
business yeah they're very light a bit
mushy at point
tastes like potatoes just a great rib
cage it tastes more plasticky mmhmm
right like it's been sitting there for a
while I think those smell is the best
thing honestly when you first get your
big match can you smell also install
they're not traditional french fries
with no please be a bit more salty but
they just find in it like salt and it's
not Christian taste as much not crispy
enough oily I can see it in my hand
I can see this don't answer yeah we
prefer rice from french fries in France
are legit they're the real thing you
know it was a whole potato
I thought the fries are fine just having
greasy and small like they've always
been our french fries a little bigger
but I don't think oh but I do Sunday
only actually a little easier to eat it
didn't seem as fresh here didn't seem as
fresh to oily the freshness is a very
important thing to eat fast food you
want it to be very fresh very tasty and
if it's not you didn't yeah I like them
I can't say I go and eat them all the
time but they're a little guilty
pleasure when I do